66 million years ago an asteroid longer
than Mount Everest is tall hurtled toward the Earth
crashing into the Gulf of Mexico.
More than 75% of plant and animal species,
including the dinosaurs, vanished.
it took over 4 million years for life to
flourish once again, but the environment
was altered forever.
So scientists were shocked when they discovered
another large impact crater, buried a kilometer
under Greenland's Hiawatha glacier.
What was even more shocking was the crater's
lack of erosion, which suggests that the
asteroid could have made impact when humans were
roaming the earth.
To be certain that their find was really an
impact crater, researchers used ice penetrating radar
to get a sense of the shape of the bedrock
underneath the ice.
The radar revealed one tell-tale characteristic:
a raised area in the center, where the ground would have
rebounded after the asteroid hit,
like water struck by a stone.
Further evidence came from the sediment draining
out of the glacier itself. Shocked quartz grains
were discovered, which could only be
formed by extraterrestrial strikes or nuclear weapons.
It was, indeed, an impact crater.
31 kilometers in diameter
that makes it one of the 25 largest known
craters in the world, though it is
smaller than the asteroid impact that
killed the dinosaurs, and the Chesapeake Bay crater.
The asteroid making the Hiawatha crater would have
needed to be enormous too, with a diameter of more
than 1.5 kilometers.
Scientists still aren't sure how young Hiawatha is, but it is
new enough that it is the only crater of its
size still visible to the naked eye--
at least, if you could see through the ice.
Evidence suggests it is between a
100,000 to 12,000 years old, though it could also be
millions of years older.
If the impact happened when Greenland was covered in
ice, which is most of the past two million years,
billions of tons of ice would have vaporized in an
instant, leading to an influx of fresh water into the
world's oceans.
Just such an influx  may have happened about
12,800 years ago, helping to set off a thousand-year
glacial period called the Younger Dryas.
But evidence for such a flood remains inconclusive.
When the asteroid did hit, faraway regions would have
felt the impact.
Hurricane-force winds would have engulfed the region
and objects as far away as a hundred kilometers
would have been leveled.
The next step is pinning down precisely when this
massive asteroid arrived.
And then the search can begin for other craters
lurking beneath the ice.